i'm andrew ross sorkin for New York
Times here in Davos Switzerland on day
two of the World Economic Forum's annual
meeting you know one of the issues that
keeps coming up and you're hearing it
over and over again is this question by
capitalism this question about free
markets especially as so many world
leaders politicians executives
regulators from around the world look at
the experience the United States and the
financial crisis in particular you know
a CEO from India said to me the other
day you know for the past 20 30 years we
looked at the US as the bastion of
capital was in the example that we hope
to be and we made that bet as he said he
took all that he said this country took
all of its chips from moved him from
black to red on the roulette table but
now we're looking at the experience that
you've had in the US and we're saying
maybe we made the wrong bet I've heard
the same thing from executives and
regulators in China the same thing for
executives and regulators in Europe and
I think it's a question that's going to
go much beyond this conference here and
it's a conversation that's going to
continue at least for the next several
years i'm andrew ross sorkin to new york
times we're on nytimes.com / davos with
news throughout the week thanks so much